[Music]
what are your names
I'm sorry
he's named right ray I remember ray I
photographed you right do you remember
years ago and your name is Lorraine
Lorraine and Timmy know you guys grew up
here in an odd West Virginia how many
years have you lived here
oh you're uh you guys have been did you
go to school you did some of your
brother some of your brothers and
sisters probably didn't go to school or
how much schooling did they get you
graduated from what you went to high
school Timmy and how about you Lorraine
she didn't and come on out
can you guys
great so tell me about your family
now I believe things that we can do to
speed up this manifestation sorry what
tell me but were you how old are you how
old are you eating tonight for dinner
sandwich so you you grew up here in odd
West Virginia your whole life and your
family you lost your brother since I was
here last tell me tell you about your
brother
what was your favorite memory ray do you
remember anything about your life and
you lost your other brother
so you lost your brother Ray's brother
Ray and Tim's brother Tim is a nephew
but there's one of the brothers that's
missing now that's I'm saying who is
that Freddie that's right Freddy's gone
how long did he die four years how did
he die how did he die so tell me about
your family
your parents tell me about your parents
of course yeah they're older now they'd
be very old what what can you tell me
about your family know you love your
parents good family
Timmy you hiding
so you hear stories about your family
that your parents were brothers sisters
or cousins or something like that
nothing like that but the mental
disorder that that Ray has what is that
from but he's a bit Freddie and Ray and
Timmy you're both kind of have that same
and Lorraine too has the same thing what
do you suppose that the cause of that
might have been Timmy you into high
school right yeah Timmy tell me but tell
me but but you remember of your of your
of your parents can you tell me anything
Lorraine what can you remember of your
family
right do you remember your brother
Freddie Freddie your brother right your
brother Freddie can you do you remember
Hey do you miss him do you miss your
brother
yeah
what's over there Oh Freddie's grave
is that Freddie's grave all right well
there's interesting seeing you guys
again thank you for letting me come by
you remember me from about ten years ago
yeah I'm sorry about your brother I'm
sorry about Freddie Lorraine Timmy thank
you for letting me come by ray I'm gonna
take off thank you for letting me come
by again nice seeing you again
you
you